we present the video mesh a new data
structure for video editing the video
mesh encodes the motion layering and 3d
structure of a video sequence in a
unified data structure intuitively it
looks like a paper cutout of the world
we illustrate our technique on a simple
educational example constructing a video
mesh begins with first tracking
distinctive features through the
sequence then we compute a de l'année
triangulation on each frame the mesh
linearly interpolate s' the motion at
vertices which is a good approximation
where the motion is smooth users specify
occlusion boundaries at a few key frames
using splines which separates the
components in the mesh splines are
advective between keyframes by the
optical flow encoded in the mesh
now we change the viewpoint to reveal
the geometry of the mesh the user
specifies the depth at a few vertices
now the video mesh looks like a 2.5 D
paper cut out
notice how the actors hand occludes his
body while remaining connected to it
through the arm such self occlusion
cannot be represented by traditional
layers without arbitrarily cutting the
arm
in contrast the video mesh naturally
encodes these topological configurations
we use off-the-shelf matting to
decompose the texture we in paint the
missing parts of the scene using texture
synthesis once we have the video mesh we
can use classical computer graphics
techniques for special effects for
instance we simulate a large aperture
lens with a shallow depth of field by
rendering the scene several times from
viewpoints sampled over the aperture the
user clicks to choose the plane InFocus
we can also composite a simulation of
volumetric smoke note how the
attenuation depends on the depth of the
scene
this sequence features a static camera
with complex occlusions between the
columns
the user needs to specify only the
primary occlusion boundaries since the
camera is static we interactively assign
depth using simple image based modeling
tools we insert a ground plane and model
the columns and the actor as vertical
facades
since the actor is a single connected
component in the video mesh we can copy
him in space and time to turn him into a
crowd since we have 3d geometry we can
interactively manipulate the actor
we can also refocus the camera
move the camera and simulate the vertigo
effect by moving the camera backward
while zooming in so that the main object
does not change size since we have the
3d geometry of the scene we can adjust
the lighting as well as simulate a fog
effect that accounts for the depth at
each pixel this allows us to render the
sequence as if it were shot at night
this sequence features a moving camera
in a scene with multiple rigidly moving
objects we use off-the-shelf structure
for motion to recover 3d vertex
positions and the camera path in this
case structure for motion was applied
independently on the chasis and lid of
the copier and registered into the same
coordinate system we composite multiple
copies of another video mesh into the
scene while interactively changing the
viewpoint notice the parallax induced by
the changing viewpoint the inset shows
the input video
this video of a river bank near the
notre-dame Cathedral features complex
geometry and occlusions between
buildings we model the 3d geometry using
the same image based tools we cut the
mesh at the primary occlusion boundaries
with splines insert two ground planes
and model the buildings with vertical
facades the video mesh lets us move the
camera onto the roof of the boat as it
sails down the river
you